why is it when
men do something for women
it's like oh that's so nice of you and
they don't think of
the
the things that it took to do that and
say like like i appreciate it more and
i'm not saying all women do this but
it's like that's nice of you because
you're supposed to be able to do
something for me like why
why is that it's it's our society it's
everything i'm telling you once you see
it you can't unsee it like everything is
just geared towards women
everything and anytime a man does
something great they minimize it or try
to say a woman did it too
that is true
i have
i have done that before and i'm like
why a woman's done that yeah
like and i don't think it's because like
people are like i don't think you were
being like an unkind person i just think
like we like that that's we've been i
hate to say it but like brainwashed from
such a young age to like
think like this yeah
man just red phil stuff
um i'm not so sure that that's a social
obligation because many other people
would have done it had it been a social
obligation
he said what he was concerned about he
saw that his wife was suffering with her
monthly period and
had to choose between feeding her family
and taking care of herself properly and
chose to feed her family and thought he
would do something about that that goes
way past nice especially given what he
had to suffer through to do all the
experimentation that produced his his
eventual technology so like i this whole
patriarchy thing i think you have no
idea how pernicious and dangerous it is
well no i don't i really don't go
throughout history have fundamentally
cooperated to push back against the
absolute catastrophe of existence a
terrible death rate the probability of
chronic starvation early death disease
the difficulty of raising children with
all the death that was associated with
that and to look backwards in time and
say well basically what happened was men
took the upper hand and persecuted women
in this tyrannical patriarchy it's
absolutely dreadful misreading of
history it's a terrible thing to teach
young women and it's a horrible thing to
inflict upon men i mean i absolutely
disagree with you i think that's like
saying
slavery in the u.s was actually most
people cooperate well no you didn't you
had a system where one set of people
owned another set of people and until
women got full legal rights they could
own property themselves they could work
essentially they were owned they were
first
owned by their
the domination by men yeah he said that
you thought that what emancipated women
primarily in the 20th century was
technological revolution no not
primarily but that's one of two i think
that's two things primarily no i think
the pill was a primary force in the
emancipation of women i think
of tampons let's say or the or the
provision of proper sanitary uh
facilities toilets and that sort of
thing you're you're thinking instead it
was the action of courageous feminists
in the 1920s that produced a social
revolution that overthrew the patriarchy
that's your theory yeah that's a foolish
theory well i'm very sorry to hear you
say that but i think to you quote you in
the kathy newman interview i think it's
a multivariate right i think there are
lots of different things that all
contributed then let's not be assuming
that the western society was a
tyrannical patriarchy that's one of them
and then other things happened as well
so you have the pale you have the
dishwasher and white goods labor-saving
devices in the home i think all of those
were really important but you also have
things like campaigns for the vote yes
you also have things like that yes so
how when in a system that existed in
england until 1918 when why would you
even want to look at history like that
like what what's your what's your goal
because i think the people who don't
look at history are condemned to repeat
it and i think that we we're gonna what
are we gonna do repeat the the
persecution of women that do you think
that's a realistic possibility yeah
we're sitting here you see that we're
sitting here in america right where
we've just had a fifth judge appointed
to the supreme court who is now
anti-abortion is now conservative i
think that abortion rights are
accidentally fundamental to women being
able to function as full humans in
society and i think that is now under
threat in america i think it is
extremely smug and complacent to think
civilization has peaked it's all upwards
from here
so to be able to
function
in this world
like nothing else to be able to function
like that that's the thing that we need
to function
abortion that's that's the thing we need
to function that's sexist i don't like
if anything
you can't not have sex like
that's the thing we need to function
like out of everything oh my god or i
don't know get married or i don't know
use like 20 million forms of birth
control
abortion
that's what's going to help me build
this youtube channel that's that's ah
that's the that's the key right there
thank you
now that i know this yeah i would have
man i would be
far along in my life
yo that that's wow
the fact that she said that i'm like she
said that's the key
to women functioning
interesting is it isn't it interesting i
never thought about before i mean i have
now because i watched this a couple
years ago but i never thought about
like
that it wasn't like that women were
oppressed so much it was more like men
were like taming the world almost yeah
that that's what i wanted to say i was
trying to remember it yeah
if you think about
when she said that that the girls were
owned by their fathers then essentially
owned by
their husbands
can you help me understand what she
meant by that
uh well i think it's like the feminist
worldview is that like men are bad
and men did not have the best interests
of women so like for example women
couldn't vote but did you know the
majority of women didn't want to vote
yeah like if you think about way back
when
life
men were the breadwinners and women were
at home so essentially the people that
are voting is affecting them if you're
at home all day raising a kid it's not
really going to
affect you for my knowledge but if
you're on the work field and there's
laws that are putting being put in place
that affect you in the workforce just in
life in general that you are in 24 7.
then you have a say in it
but if it
doesn't affect you and i never thought
about that until now i was like huh well
and uh it came with the draft so that's
why we didn't want to vote because like
then you would have to be drafted
yeah and i kind of want to return our
rights
i don't want to have the opportunity to
be drafted
thanks no no no i want to return all of
our rights i want to go back to the
kitchen
you see i hate driving let's give it
back
pearl needs a driver if anybody is a
driver out there
anyone
anyone want to let me i don't really
like cleaning though i'll be a poor
housewife
a poor housewife like a bad one
she'll do the bare minimum if you're
looking for a bare minimum housewife do
you know what they didn't think about
everything's automated nowadays if we
just stuck it out
now back then they had to hand wash the
lawn yeah i would have been horrible i'd
have been like no i'm not doing this you
know what i'm saying though like if we
just waited another 50 years everything
would have been automated house what so
much easier yep housewives would have
been
gucci i probably would not be in school
if
if they didn't have women's rights i'd
probably be at home with what are we
doing
why
what
i'm grateful i wouldn't be in student
debt though that would be debt-free
i'm grateful
yeah